who's popping your is your girl car TV
and you backed away easy and we in
Atlanta baby and they made me take off
my shoes but Donna Donna come up because
I've been gettin done okay thank you
very much goodbye will you tell me about
this here cuz it is amazing Oh what I'm
saying give me you give me you sexy
aunty vibe because I am behind sexy
aunty no there's more than sexy auntie
you know the fashion yeah yeah I want to
ask you cuz you're performing here this
Saturday right
Saturday night wouldn't it be
interesting since you were in town and
maroon 5 has a song girls like you
wouldn't be the perfect time for you to
pop up during a halftime show it
wouldn't be no no okay alright I was
just you know everybody wants speculated
maybe they're they're expecting a lot of
famous women to come out there during
that and that is a video that has what a
billion views yes yeah over a billion
views it might be two billion views so
it could be interesting if you popped up
up nothing on what I stand you know what
I'm saying I know where I stand I'm
doing other things because you know no
they let's make money out of us by not
made a little money out of them but it
is there certain things I just can't
push my limits mm-hmm I just wanted my
soul wouldn't feel right but I know me
and maroon 5 we're gonna have a lots of
performances coming coming on especially
because that's all it just means so much
to me yeah it feels like it's like the
female empowerment song of the like
decade I mean you know when I was when I
was pregnant
mmm-hmm like and me having a girl inside
of me and this is like hearing the song
they just I
tune of a couple of times so yeah I
don't probably don't even know that but
is this true
alright here's some you know the other
day you were walking I can't remember
where you were walking and someone I
asked you if you and offset of working
things out and you said we're working
working you know yeah working it out
yeah yeah we can see the family back
together
I mean we're always gonna be a family
that's together yeah yeah baby love us
both just wanna you know it's like like
having a baby that like the whole world
wants to see and watch and no you just
have to be very already protective and
that's something that we always gotta
like make sure we always keep
communication okay Aaron make sure that
we see my schedule is so crazy and it's
you're like spending time these are the
times that the baby's like you know they
recognize the parents they want to be
close to their parents all the time yeah
so I sense what I'm hearing from you is
hope there is hope
oh and how is culture doing how do you
do is she's so cute I love her yeah yes
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's undescribable it's
like like love joy it's a switch mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying it's like
automatic smiled right it's automatic
worries sad you know what I'm saying
that cuz that you know my baby had a
cold and I never felt like like so sad
and I wanted to cry and so worried like
I just oh god it's crazy so is
everything
she's never she means everything to you
yes and I think I mean I mean everything
sir
they were not she sees me she kicks her
fee so fast it's like she loves me when
she sees you does she go crazy as soon
as you walk in the room crazy yes
so if one brings you this much joy would
you double the joy I want to have more
kids you do more kids that sounds like
many you know how whatever if my body
could take and I feel like I can take
you know everybody so it's easy to be
like oh I want five four kids but it's
like can you really take that you know
it's as I feel like the more my baby
grows I see like the different levels
mm-hmm and this is gonna be different
levels all the time from one year old to
going around chasing them making sure
they don't put things in the mouth too
you know five year old when they start
going to school learning things
interacting with other kids it's always
gonna be different levels yeah of course
all right well we're waiting on the next
few um by the way everyone I mean people
went crazy when you posted your um your
viral thing about the shutdown but have
you heard down the people are asking
that you make the Democratic response to
the State of the Union would you do that
would you make the Democratic response
for the State of the Union I mean I will
they didn't need understand all that I
might say a couple of curse words I'm
I'm very passionate with everything that
did I say but it's a little scary you
know
like when I made that statement about
the government shutdown yeah which is a
statement that I feel like you know you
don't really need a research - you gotta
watch the news so you can know what's
going on and I have all these
conservatives is
say the meanest things to me and the
most dangerous things and then when I
used to go to their page they have these
crazy rifles out oh my god you know what
I'm just gonna stay in my place but then
again is I I gotta say a couple of
things cuz I love this country and I pay
a lot of taxes to live here right yeah
you know I pay a lot of taxes now don't
you isn't it funny start making you
learn quick about those tacks oh yeah
yeah I hear you
do you think though that also with new
music and the way your elevated sense
that you are have become this important
role model for so many young women I see
you know I see and sometimes it's a hard
job because it's like I know that I
gotta set an example but then it's just
like it's like I feel like to some
people they feel like setting an example
is being this angel and then say I'm not
an angel you're not an angel what a
shock
ya know people expect you to act like a
Disney Channel star and is that I'm not
that you know sometimes I'm very sexual
sometimes I say naughty things and is
that I don't want to like pause myself
from doing what I want to do because I'm
like this role model you know woman to
who you know something as a grown woman
I feel like I should do and say what I
want